le rideau va tomber sur le bistrot de la
scène après 35 ans d'existence sauf coup
de théâtre cette salle de spectacles
associatif devrait fermer définitivement
à la fin d'année la crise sanitaire aura
eu raison de cette institution
dijonnaise qui depuis de nombreuses
années déjà connaissez des fins de mois
difficiles
le déficit s'élève aujourd'hui à 50000
euros actuellement mais sur une jauge de
65 70 personnes maximum et notre barème
de rentabilité là où on écrive lent
compte c'est en moins 100 personnes
donc chaque spectacle créé un déficit
donc on s'enfonce petit à petit avec la
fermeture du bistrot de la scène ce sont
trois salariés 6 intermittents du
spectacle et une personne en service
civique qui restent sur le carreau
le monde de la culture souffre mais à
des degrés divers à la vapeur
seuls dix concerts de la saison initiale
ont ou auront lieu d'ici la fin de
l'année c'est quatre fois moins que ce
qui était prévu
la salle de musiques actuelles vient
donc de dévoiler 12 nouvelles dates qui
colle à la donne sanitaire une jauge
limitée à 200 places assises
au menu des artistes en format intimiste
des spectacles jeune public ou des
ciné-concerts cette démarche
volontariste alors - tous l'urgence
économique de la vapeur en tant que tel
puisque on en a quand même la chance de
train et qui ont subventionné donc de
pouvoir quand même se maintenir malgré
la situation délicate mais par contre
c'est pas forcément le cas
de tous les artistes des techniciens des
sites de production avec lesquels on
travaille donc c'est aussi maintenir un
certain niveau d'activité pour toute la
filière professionnelle
la vapeur le fait aussi pour le public
reste à savoir si la formule le séduira
assez pour dépasser la frilosité
ambiante